bonjour patrick baz et merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors vous avez vu
arriver beaucoup de blessés dans
l'hôpital dans lequel vous travaillez
oui effectivement on a recensé 342
blessés
il ya eu 14 décès pour la soirée de
mardi
alors toutes spécialités confondues moi
je suis ophtalmologiste nous avons dû
avoir une vingtaine de deux gros
traumatisme oculaire
certains ont été opérés d'autres ont été
évacués sur les autres hôpitaux
quels sont les blessures les plus
nombreuses que vous avez eue a retrouvé
hier dans ses passions qui sont arrivés
en ophtalmologie ça allait d'une
éclatement total de l'oeil ça pouvait
être une plaie de l'oeil ça pouvait être
tout simplement un bris de verre au
niveau de l'oeil sans aucune gravité
mais du point de vue général il ya eu
des traumatismes orthopédiques des
traumatismes crâniens des traumat
essentiellement traumatisme crânien et
orthopédiques avec le couronnais virus
qui se propage également au liban est ce
que vous craignez un manque de place
dans votre hôpital et dans les autres
hôpitaux du pays
oui c'est sûr c'est à dire que s'il ya
des cas graves de colonna virus
on va être un peu coincé pour les
hospitaliser on espère qu'il n'aura pas
maintenant tous les malades qu'on peut
faire sortir rapidement de l'hôpital on
le fait voilà bah je nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de 4 colonna virus à l'hôtel
dieu de france 1 donc c'est déjà c'est
déjà ça ils vont surtout vers les
hôpitaux publics
mais voilà côté traumatisme
nous on a eu beaucoup de cas plus
généralement patrick baz le liban fait
face à une crise multiforme économiques
sanitaires politiques et humanitaires
après ces deux explosions de mardi à
beyrouth quelle est votre vision de la
situation au liban
écoutez le peuple est fatigué le peuple
est triste et le peuple est très en
colère pour tout ce qui se passe
écoutez il ya une malédiction qui tombe
sur le liban depuis octobre nous vivons
une crise économique très dur qui va en
s'aggravant
en plus le colonat virus vient aggraver
les choses parce qu'il a bloqué le pays
pendant deux mois et maintenant nous
avons se lit sur le gâteau cette
explosion qui a endommagé beyrouth
donc même les gens qui s'en sortait plus
ou moins ne peuvent plus s'en sortir ils
ont perdu déjà leur emploi ou une partie
de leur salaire
beaucoup d'entreprises ont fermé et
maintenant ils perdent leur maison leur
santé et leur vie donc on est au fond du
gouffre les gens sont tous les ans
coller mais ils sont tellement fatigué
que j'ai l'impression que il n'arrive
pas à exprimer leur colère aujourd'hui
mais si ça continue ils vont l'expliquer
il exprimé un jour ou l'autre vous qui
êtes confrontés aux patients dans un
pays qui a déjà connu la guerre vous
pensez que les libanais vont avoir le
moral pour pour continuer à avancer
malgré ce dernier drame
oui le peuple libanais garde toujours un
petit espoir mais cet espoir va en
s'amenuisant pendant la guerre civile
qui a duré 15 ans il n'y avait pas de de
crise économique et financière comme
aujourd'hui
donc les gens pouvaient quitter une
région
en guerre pour aller se réfugier dans
une autre région mais ils pouvaient
continuer à travailler et à vivre
décemment
aujourd'hui la crise économique fait que
quand il ya un problème comme celui qui
a eu il ya deux jours on ne sait plus
comment s'en sortir
c'est ça qui est dramatique merci
beaucoup patrick qui a base pour cet
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin chirurgien à l'hôtel dieu de
france à beyrouth merci